egg you know house of cards not the only
thing you can start streaming on Netflix
next week the day after Memorial Day
check out f is for family the new
animated Netflix series about the Murphy
family and the man who plays the
short-tempered war veteran raising three
children in suburban Pennsylvania dad
patriarch of the family frank is the man
who is the co-creator of f is for family
back here on the show bill burr good to
see you sir I don't know we wanted
Pennsylvania is that right you're not
amend I don't know why reading synopsis
right here we're not allowed to say
where we were in the United States
because we got you as we animated it
through France and and they get like a I
don't know it's a whole money thing they
get like it's something from the
government if you do your animation
there and then they okay so they had a
stipulation yet have one European
character whatever the hell that means
that's what we got the the concentration
camp survivor guy that's your choice of
a European character no not all European
characters you could million you a young
you ran into people I mean what's the
70s it was only like 30 years before
they need ever once while to someone
with with the number I know that in like
New York as it was unreal so that was it
and then you weren't allowed to say that
it was um that it that it was in the
u.s. well we were just a so that's our
you sort of like well we won't assume
for you or they think it's New England
like it's Boston oh my god I don't know
where it is but okay so not that is not
confirmed I hope I didn't screw over
here did you just do it Giselle to me it
doesn't it was funny I didn't even know
that that happens to you guys tell me I
believe it I just watched the games I
don't watch pregame I don't watch
postgame I don't want Jenny that yeah I
just literally watch the game and
Charlie Rose is that Charlie Rose just
basically ask the innocent question of
like are you trying to get Tom to retire
haha and in their conversation that
ensued she started talking about yeah
Tom gets concussions and he had won last
year and he wasn't you know I'm a report
for it and that's what law was asking
you off-camera we might as well bring it
on camera here is there like an
equivalent of comedian equivalent where
your wife was being interviewed and she
throws you under a little bit of a bus
that would be like yeah just bill steel
jokes would be like
yeah you know he kind of swipes one here
there I guess I don't see well I guess
that's the only you could do that would
really other than that I'm trying to
think what should not be great if there
was an injury report for comedians like
what would be on an injury report for
comedians bill what would be on there
like I would let you quite a big
physical comics uh-huh yeah you'd
probably mess up your back I lean on the
mics man I also don't know how to tell a
joke really so I have to scream I act so
I think I'd be out a couple of days with
it some throat injury bones box but
would there be like a like a certain
cirrhosis or something like that
question overall yeah definitely you
know I got a fatty liver I slept like a
nice rib eye at this point I like loosen
you do I do
I don't like how I feel the next day so
now my older age I just I sort of picked
my spots which is basically the entire
time I'm on the road do you do you may
just loneliness it's like I don't want
to go back to the hotel room by myself
now and just be sitting there waiting to
fall asleep you're wired up from the
show so you just go out you have a few
and then you have a few more I was just
in Saskatoon Saskatchewan we want to be
crazy Bar tattoo everybody all tatted up
and stuff they were fun people but
people would just they were throwing
down you get caught up an XT know they
bring the hockey stick over with the
shots in it and you just totally do
shots off my hockey I never done it and
I was in Canada I am on my best behavior
when I'm in another country if that's
what they do I applied that's what
that's what they say that's the phrase
went in Saskatoon yeah do shot the hawk
you see locals exactly so there's a lot
of inconsistent I wouldn't think that's
yeah very good toon Inc a lot of people
like tired they're like super nice and
then they're just also like cat it up
like they're in biker gangs like
somebody just this one beautiful woman
our whole leg done I don't get the leg
tattoo
tattoos look good up like above the
waist like down here I mean you have a
piece of whatever look good but once you
just do the whole sleeve on your leg
well I always think about this when I
see people who are tatted up is like
what happens when you're knock on wood
70 80 years old and what happens then
when you get the whole sleeves is a
senior citizen you know being and
investing in some sort of tattoo removal
service how about you because it's a
cloud you know I don't have any no no no
I'm just saying how about you
you're thinking is what I'm saying yeah
because I see them now because I go to
some of the old hair metal band shows
every once awhile I see what my
generation looks like now that none of
them p90x and they're all getting all
stretched out and faded it's we don't
want to do it fortunately I'm so pasty
with freckles like I knew it wouldn't
look good unless I got like a cheetah or
something and colored in like the
freckles so I never got one
filbert here on the Rich Eisen show do
you have a pop while watching the
Celtics or something like that or where
you don't you know I'm home I don't I
got a little one at home so I've been
watching the Celtics and you know we got
destroyed the first two games and
somehow won the third game I was on the
road saw a little bit of that and last
night I caught like the first quarter I
just been hyping this stuff right so
what do you what do you think the the
Celtics should do you know with their
did you know they did what they should
have done which is they did make a trade
at the Etihad didn't make a move with
the trade deadline right kept all their
players kept all their draft picks you
just got to wait for LeBron to kind of
get a little older Bryan hopeful maybe
somebody from that team takes off it's
just like Tom Brady just waiting the guy
out there's certain guys that are in the
league it's like you're not going to
beat this guy and I thought those first
two games I just felt like the Cavaliers
maybe had a chip on the shoulder that
they were saying oh the Celtics are the
number one seed and I'm sure he's
looking
LeBron's look and go like who's going to
stop me on you teamlack Kelly Olynyk
who's been on the wrong side of the
poster its entire career except for that
game seven which was one of my favorite
things favorite Wizards yeah I turned it
watching him light it up all of a sudden
out of nowhere and they started chanting
his name and I forgot so I started
watching Celtics hardcore again about a
year and a half ago and a buddy mine
came up and was a Knicks fan so I was
like you know be a good host so if I'm
an NHL guy I got the NBA package and I
started watching us I was like we didn't
have a big man we don't rebound and we
live and die by the three and I'm like
we're not even make the playoffs because
when I was a kid you couldn't make the
playoffs doing that and then they just
started winning doing that and I kind of
started buying into it
and thought that we had a shot against
Cleve but once once Isiah went down I
knew we would I know now the
conversation is like to even keep him
because they won the game three without
him now what do you do what is that I
forget how we got there in one game
they win without them and then all of a
sudden it's like this guy a liability
it's like that's how we got there but I
mean what it's in the same way like if
you have one bad gig now suddenly we
could do shows without you I mean could
you imagine if that was the way it would
be the world and for khabees I don't
know why that happens but I remember
when you know every when Tom Brady went
down and Castle yeah Matt castle and
everyone was freaking out about him
because he went 11 and five with the 16
and no team bill at halftime of Super
Bowl 51 all you had to look at on
Twitter was put Garoppolo in and that if
honestly that was happening at halftime
as Gaga is catching a football during
her half-time people know you know any
alayan
it's time for Garoppolo put him in and
this proves that Brady's done with the
Patriots and you know what that was
though was when he threw that pick six
he's going to show the tape when he
dives to try to tackle that cornerback
it looked like somebody threw a dead
body out of a car was almost unathletic
I've ever seen my like Tom Brady in the
pocket just anime looks like an
astronaut but when he tries to run
somebody down yeah well Vince Wilfork
used to say he could beat him in a
40-yard dash and I was thinking he was
just joking when I saw that just cut it
down yeah bill burr f is for family
we're back in 60 seconds you stick
around for them absolutely all right
we're here with Bill burr we're gonna
ask him the poll question all right
we're going to get his two cents on our
poll question today
don't answer it yet but would you rather
see a major league sequel or sequel to
Top Gun or neither that's bill burr next
in 60 seconds on the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
DirecTV is the leader in 4k Ultra HD in
the first US pay TV provider to bring
you live sports in 4k and then there's
channel 104 which is dedicated to 4k
with movies documentaries in audience
network content like this show bilberry
you might notice we're double camera up
today you see the two cameras I didn't
know is back on TV I thought you're just
doing a live read here none of it we are
we're live well I saw no cast my
libraries man hello that's the
next-level stuff that I do so TV's going
to get even clearer for you just in time
we're shooting you for our 4k this is
this is content this is 4k content
that's going to appear on Direct TV 4k
channels Wow look at that
DirecTV is your leader and everything
all those shadows behind your desk I
feel like I can enjoy your show even
more well now you you know be great
eventually they're going to get a
definition whatever
H whatever would you say was for K 5
once they get up to about 7 I think then
people can finally non hockey fans will
finally be able to see the puck can I
octopod remember when Fox put the glow
on the puck I know and they got so much
crap and they were actually ahead at
that time because now you look at the
NFL and they got all kinds of stuff on
the screen yeah it was just the flames
coming out the back I guess it probably
wasn't a good idea at some times the
glowing puck when the pup was in the
corner the glow would be in the stands
yeah and you as you're trying to swap at
the [ __ ] and they're digging out of the
corner glow would begin a third NHL I
love that they usually don't make the
right move
and because it keeps it like a sort of a
rogue sport I like that it's number four
I like that people can't they don't
understand why they fight they don't
know where it is and I I enjoy that and
I love when people lie every four years
and when they watch Olympic hockey was
like see this is the way it was like I
would watch it all the time it's like
you wouldn't what does an all-star game
of everybody in the league playing yeah
of course you would watch why wouldn't
you watch with everything on the line I
miss I miss the like when I came up in
the 80s that was like the second sort of
I think Golden Age in hockey obviously I
missed the first one
but it was like the perfect combination
of fights and and finesse players well
and the Oilers came in and just over it
just took finestatt to the new level oh
yeah well they're the reason why there's
no more
four-on-four because back in the day
when you had a fight two guys went off
the ice and then it became four on four
and then just that little bit of open
ice those guys if they would hurry and
all of you all those yes I see a so
you're watching the Predators are you
watching the Predators of Nashville
getting into hockey how about that I
know I went to a game didn't you do your
last stand-up gig wasn't that it yeah I
did it the the Ryman right and which is
the original place of the Grand Ole Opry
but I went to a Predators game like
within the first two three years of them
becoming a franchise and like they
didn't know anything about hockey and I
remember like the puck one in the corner
and those two guys going for the puck
and this lady behind me she yell does
she go squish him which I never heard at
a hockey game you know I think there was
something about checking but now to hear
like look at section 303 and they got a
chance that they did sounds like a
college game and then just being a
Bruins fan in a Canadians hater I love
that the Canadians get rid of pique
subhan and now he's going to the finals
because I always tease them that the
reason why they haven't won a Cup since
93 was the curse of Patrick wah which
was it for people who don't watch hockey
basically his last game there he was
having a bad game and they wouldn't pull
him and he let in like something like
five or six goals and then he finally he
made like a routine safe in the Habs
fans game the old like you know great
you finally did it and you saw both of
his gloves go up he was given the crowd
the finger and he skated over to the
bench and that's back when like you know
there was like no back like the crowd
was right there and you told the owners
like I just played my last game for you
guys he's all pissed off hissed yeah and
then he then he won two more for the
Avalanche so it's the only thing is a
Bruins fan that I can trash the
Canadiens yeah it's a Red Sox fan versus
Yankees as much as we won three we're
never going to catch them they want you
know 27 and in that is the I Madsen
accurate accounting ya member of Yankee
champions and the Canadian - what 24 or
something well I mean the interesting
thing about the the curse that I heard
the reason why Canada has not won a Cup
since 93 is the curse of Marty McSorley
that the Canadiens knew that McSorley's
stick when he played for the LA Kings
was illegal and they call them out on
that and they wound up beating the Kings
in that series and that's kind of
you know an unwritten rule it's like
week you know like Billy Martin going
and with the pine tar with George Brett
right right there's a kind of a kind of
a project yeah that's the one I've heard
all right no one was I like cursive
Patrick lot better because it completely
blames the Canadian did you go straight
on that one
Wilbur here on the show and speaking of
the Red Sox you know about that you
wanted ten million dollars what are we
second to last place I know you're too
old I used to be used to call them the
evil empire now the Yankees are like
doing it where they got that Aaron Judge
to six foot seven right fielders yes and
he's another guy that's all like humble
I don't know how the Yankees do that
they always finally like the Derek Jeter
totally down-to-earth
yeah like I don't think anybody did it
better than Jeter as far as like I agree
with you in that public eye I think he's
the promoter and a cue maybe lifestyles
ever lived and nobody got upset right
because they're a winner and you hate
Derek Jeter I do not like it I read the
doctor and how exactly really
unavailable how can you hate Abel
oh come on bill so you got nothing come
on Bill with it you got nothing waiting
drama guys is everything he jumps into
the stands when he didn't have to Jeremy
Giambi was safe what else
Phil you're making us look petty come on
man just give it up he's gone he can't
hurt us anymore and this is a guy I
don't hurt none this is a guy who's so
excited about the ring based on a guy
who put a red sharpie stain on his sock
we could go there great what are you
guys talking about the players Journal
you read that yeah and I thinks it's out
of charter there will be blood that's
one of the best articles up but he might
tell me to read this and and the reason
why I brought up the Red Sox are you
roasting David Ortiz with drunk are you
doing that yes this is gonna be the
hardest roast ever because everybody up
there is like a champion so I mean yeah
where do you I don't and I don't have a
problem care what you did in your
personal life so where you going to go
honey how do you roast
I'm gonna get mad that they didn't bring
Mike Torres or Tony Eason on it give me
some sort of a light up here no
disrespect to those guys but there's got
to be something that you did wrong does
even do you even know where Mike Torres
is ed out
tone bill go ahead tell him Mike Torres
was the unfortunate guy on the mound
during Red Sox history when
Bucky Dent came up to the place he came
on Homer in 78 that was the first year
that I followed them and Mike Torres was
a former Yankee too by the way
I also got I got a like knock down the
whole Aaron Boone thing because whenever
they talk about like that period yeah
they always go they say they say bucket
you know selling Babe Ruth lucky Dan
yeah Bill Buckner and then they say
Aaron Boone Aaron Boone I almost always
forget his name he never had a chance to
solidify because the next year we beat
them no I know them to advance back want
to marinate you know if that stayed in
the Cask it became like the Johnny
Walker Blue of all those other guys yeah
I just Bucky
it's difficult to just go in that order
and end up with Aaron Boone I understand
what you're saying could you heat it up
he would have but if they didn't show
ghost year you know and the worst way to
go he got hurt which was a rod trade
that's true there's a lot a lot at ACL
playing basketball and then they trade
for a rod so you and I'm looking at
Anthony Mackie and Sarah Tiana is doing
it huh true comedian Sarah Tiana who is
can I can I say it say what exactly who
she is in the Rich Eisen show lore are
you sure Chris Brockman's girlfriend my
god right over there
all right sold in my life is I had no
idea yes I just felt like when you go to
town and it's like the guy who opens for
you he's doing our local references like
oh this guy is going to be down at
hockey's at 9:00 a.m. because he's from
Tuscaloosa and everyone not to you
everything like I have no idea what
everybody's talking about
Chris Javon ready to get into the inner
romances of the show when are we
bringing up our succeed it's sometimes
difficult to pry anything personal out
of Rockman Chris Evans is going to be
there I can feel the tension no not
really good that way you don't we but
you know what you could feel it you
could see the tension in 4k right now oh
yeah high-definition 4k so f is for
family is this about your family Lucas
Lee based on childhood stories that I
was telling on stage which and you know
at the beginning part of my career
everybody liked them and laughed and
understood them and then as I became the
old comic and the Millennials came up
and they had more of a understanding
childhood and people paying attention to
him and not you know
keys to the house they would start to
kind of grown and be Oh Oh like the
stories though I just thought one day
what if I animated them and that kind of
led to me meeting Vince Vaughn's company
wild west and then the great Mike Price
from The Simpsons came on and then
that's when it took off and today we are
in streaming on May the 30th on Netflix
laura dern has plays the voice of your
wife sue you play Frank Justin Long yeah
and Rockwell Dave Koechner Debi
Derryberry mo Collins Ali Reinhardt it's
just a murderer oh it is it's a great
list of Kevin Michael Richardson we got
everybody that's great
and Jay Miller TJ Miller PJ Mellon rift
he's a baby is that and that's all about
a family the Murphy family raised in a
in an undisclosed location undisclosed
sort of Rust Belt
incursion they may or may not be in the
United States of America I don't mess
with the money that's the budget on the
show you're the best bill burr you are
the best at Bill burr right here on the
Rich Eisen show on Twitter um we are
back to set up the rest of the week here
and we'll sneak in a phone call before
we get dark life
you think so I hope so no no news either
wasting what we'll talk about when we
get back okay Bober with a hot take
going out the door here on the rich
object so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slo-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about